[Music]
guys there's a reason tekken 7 is so
popular bandai namco got the formula
just right for this latest iteration of
the Mishima family opera from the slow
mo to the hits parks to the music to the
blue stuff this game was built for pure
excitement whether you're a new fan or a
veteran of the scene and what in all of
these sports is more exciting than a
comeback we've seen our fair share of
underdog runs and individual comeback
rounds since fated retribution hit
Japanese arcades not quite three years
ago so we thought it was about time that
we gave you what we think are the top 10
impossible comeback rounds from Tekken 7
kicking off this list or should we say
grappling his way to the number 10 spot
is a true master of King Loman things
can look pretty grim when you're down to
a sliver of help against a jacked robot
with a mohawk at the biggest fighting
game event of the year but a whiffed
cossack kick was all the american needed
to retake control of the round capping
it off with an epic finish and an
equally hype pop off
[Applause]
we're given the brown let go budget like
that no let the world out you are here
to play yeah Jim top eight evolution
winners sign winners winners for America
little margin doing it coming in at the
number nine spot is this losers finals
round between book and John ding from
tiger uppercut 2018 playing on home soil
the type layer took a beating right out
of the gates but books follow-up
sequence was absolutely flawless much
like Norma jins perfectly quaffed hair
oh no Jesus
so does what is that Bob maybe it was
better if it didn't felt me bring keep
the fighters right now man I was like 90
percent the book is not out the same
John punching the legs
come on foot come on there we go right
back after my man in a 90 percent damage
combo said now I got this round what
Abby's crowd goes crazy right there our
number eight entry comes courtesy of the
Jimmy J Tran who was on the ropes
against the legendary knee in this group
stage match from the 2017 Tekken World
Tour Finals when you're down to the
final round the last thing you want to
do is with your rage drive but blue
stuff warped no blue stuff
never count Brian out
great time is blocked right no more
right now oh it's not over just yet with
the low prayer Jimmy stand alive
fighting back well you gotta talk
doesn't go for it oh my god down the way
Jimmy can lend one lakh and you can
still get the round and the game and the
set oh the sock believe what a compact
the crowd is going and singing
[Applause]
wow what a match coming in at the number
seven spot is this caudal core round
from the 2018 Tekken world tours last
chance qualifier now the American starts
off the round pretty strong but a clutch
sidestep from the law player means
things go downhill fast for ELISA but as
it turns out chainsaws and missiles are
just the kind of weapons you need to
keep it close baby you think you're
gonna win and snatch it away this heart
stopper of a match between John ding and
dojin comes in at the number 6 spot on
our list both players were on match
point at the 2017 manila cup with the
Shaheen player decimating lucky Chloe in
the opening seconds of the round one hit
away from death John dang turns on that
lucky Chloe magic taking doujin from
coast-to-coast for the wind jumping one
one it away my heart
my god Jah dig finishing what - oh my
god what was that that was antennas
eliminated ocean that was oh my god it
could not have done a home back that was
a hole my god at the halfway point on
our list is around from this nail-biter
of a grand final set between st. and qu
Dan's at NorCal regionals 2018 a bracket
reset seems all but inevitable as the
devil jin took saints jack seven down to
a nearly imperceptible amount of health
but st. did his best
Undertaker impression and landed a
piledriver that would spark a comeback
we won't soon forget
with the clutch low carry oh my god that
was crazy
give it up give it up for C turns on
ultra big problem oh that was
some good-ass Tekken oh holy crap
our number four entry sees little Majan
on the wrong side of a comeback against
JD CR at the vote 2018 now JD CR is one
of if not the greatest Tekken 7 player
of all time and this round shows us
exactly why after playing like a man
possessed throughout the weekend it's no
secret that the American crowd was on
little imagine side and who could blame
him but even on match point with no
health and so much work to do the Korean
kept his cool and did what he does best
in March and he is on a tear right now
he on the verge of setting Jewish New
York and losers oh my God he's good my
gosh he's gonna have to be careful
though he's in rage he's gonna beat him
he asked me oh you gotta be and that's
something that you rarely get hit by but
JD's here our regular time look at the
time he's gonna have to either stay on
the ground the time
JDC I was an amazing cook
he's from the future he knew it he's
from the future he's already seen it oh
no this momentum ship I'm not liking it
here JDC are looking to come out on top
speaking of JDC are the number three
spot on our list goes to die back for
his insane finish to this round against
the korean god at CEO 2018 bet you
didn't expect to see Oscar on this list
down a game against the Dragunov dime
back quickly found himself one eye gouge
away from death until well he didn't he
can land a rage art somehow maybe a rage
that we can make back a lot out all
opportunity NES great strike as well huh
kick a man oh okay cool oh don't give
these guys any more water our runner-up
spot goes to Koo Dawn's against JD CR at
the 2018 Tekken World Tour Finals rockin
the edge Lord asked here that is devil
jin who don pulls off this devilish play
against the dragon off with a literal
magic pixel of health
[Music]
ready to the wall big damage and look at
the life lead on the side JDC are
already gone
oh nice temple inhale sweet oh my god
you've never done that oh not like this
don't somebody's gonna bring it back
again
oh it simply doesn't get any closer than
our number one entry it's neuroma versus
guess who JDC are the living legend uses
hey Hachi of all characters to mount the
comeback to end all comebacks against
Jack
Jadis yotz yotz up first game you know I
might even say this might be a surprise
victory I mean I didn't think we would
see his hey aren't you yeah Amy knows
Mishima's and everyone has said it you
got to be on point but big combo coming
in from door unlocks oh here we go he
has them in the red potential perfect
here yep I think it's gonna get it oh
he's [ __ ]
oh no Evans dropped in there and you
definitely want to exit empty what does
the GARP is unable to get it with a big
demon uppercut in the follow-up yeah
looking towards the wall as well off it
just short for me he killed me yes ray
Jordan in that zone is y'all three proud
straight versus the robot the movement
is this - Oh je dis yo would you like to
be he may be here for a second I hope he
lied to you
I hate to you know put a strain on your
friendship but I hope he likes you man
JDC are added but three straight rounds
like huge comeback in the very end well
guys that is our list now if you do want
to see us do more tech and 7 content I
would advise you to hit the like button
sub to the channel and please let us
know in the comments section because
that really is the best way to influence
what content we do next and if you don't
I'll throw your ass off a volcano
[Music]
taquito
sang when you don't sit on a tuk-tuk so
read together thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button